[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RACHEL FRANKE:
It's very exciting.
I wasn't expecting
to be part of it.
I think it's really cool that
she does outreach like this.
Her music director was
saying that whenever
they have the
opportunity to do so,
they try to get people
within the community
to join them on their
concerts, which is thrilling.
Hi.
ALIA VINSON: We're
trying to figure out
who we are as performers.
And so to really
be around and be
on the same stage as such
amazing and iconic performer,
it's a huge learning
experience for us.
And so I'm just really
excited to learn
from just watching her.
[VOCAL WARM-UPS]
All right.Let's do it.
JACKSON WUJEK:
Well, you never know
what's coming your
way, especially
at a great program like this.
Being able to work with a
person that you'd be able to--
that you're going to work
with in the real world
is so thrilling.
I never thought I was going
to be Kristin Chenoweth ever,
but this is a really,
really cool opportunity,
and I'm really excited.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
(SINGING) Puts us to shame.
We can bring everyone together.
Yeah.
That was good.
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you.